so to the people that say Bush could
have been behind it I don't know if the
credibility is if Bush was behind you
know like uh 9 11 for money and all this
other stuff but it can I say a little
bit from my own level of skepticism that
maybe there are somebody on the inside
that they could care less about Legacy
they want to figure out a way how to
maximize their job at the White House to
make money and we have a president today
that's done that you've seen it you've
read it it's been all over the place
that you use that last name and the job
and Clinton's been criticized for that
uh uh he's been criticized for that bite
and a lot of people have been criticized
for that so do some people get in and
use their ability to persuade and I can
only imagine like if there's a meeting
and everybody's sitting there saying
President Bush
there I I I'm we have very strong uh
data that there's weapons of mass
destruction and then you ask the
question what do you think we should do
I think we should attack and you know uh
uh defend uh our country because if we
don't we seem like we're weak and we're
not doing our part and we have to do
something about it right now now boom
you come out here you give the message
you know it's like oh my God this is
crazy this is amazing and then later on
like there was no weapons of mass
destruction so maybe somebody
manipulated a way to get somebody to
make a decision that they would have
never supported themselves I don't know
if I'm making sense it's a long-winded
question I'm asking but you don't think
somebody that gets inside has negative
motives that will use it in a way to
monetize and make money because that's
what a lot of people in politics have
been criticized for doing no I don't
think so first of all George Tenet
didn't come to the conclusion that
Saddam had wmd the CIA that his agency
did his experts his analysts
I don't know who the head of Egyptian
intelligence is but he didn't come to
the conclusion his analysts did same
thing with Israel same thing with his
friends Etc he's the guy no yeah but
that's not like they make up the facts
they have their teams of experts who go
and find the facts fine well with find
the allegations find the beliefs the
conclusions that they can put together
but let me let me talk to you about
intelligence generally speaking
one of the things that I learned at the
White House is intelligence is maddening
you know on the TV shows people make it
look like oh my God the envelope just
came in we opened it up and here's the
report from our agent in the field we
got the goods holy take action and then
come the paratroopers
most intelligence reports are mindlessly
frustrating because they're we have
reasons to believe acts but then there's
also why and then we have people who
tell us Z our analysis shows it could be
X Y or Z this is what you get for most
intelligence reports they'll put a
probability on it they say oh our
assessment is the probability leans in
the direction more of X but we don't
discount why you read one of these
things and you're what what what's your
conclusion give me a conclusion that is
why most intelligence reports
like a McKenzie or Gardener you hire
them and they say you know our
assessment is 62 chance this is where
you're losing your money and is it kind
of like that well it's it's more because
the other side North Korea Iran Russia
China gets to hide things
and it's not like we can just walk in
and say give me your stuff you can't
hide it anymore I need to know well
that's the whole game has to be a better
intelligence though yes but my point is
it doesn't always lead itself to a
hundred percent declarative knowledge it
leads itself to surmising believing
taking things and trying to piece it
together in the case of wmd they put it
together and with the exception of the
state department intelligence one of 17
different intelligence agencies in the
United States with the exception of
state every single American intelligence
Community concluded it wasn't that it
was likely it wasn't that it was
probable They concluded Saddam had
stockpile as a biological and chemical
does that mean a hundred percent what is
conclude because I like what you said
there's a sixty percentage 80 chance
there's X Y or Z what number did they
give CIO would never put a number on it
okay they're smart enough bureaucrats
not to do that
um but the famous quote was when
Georgetown said to George Bush it's a
slam dunk that he has wmd okay so now so
so so slam dunk that he's given that
that's coming from a guy George Tenet
who was the director of CIA since 96. 96
to 01 September that's five years of
experience being there you have enough
time to know who's on your team who's
capable who's not who you have to fire
who you have to keep it's not like you
don't have that experience to do that
right so uh I don't know all I think
about is like President Trump okay a guy
becomes a president you know how
something yesterday were debating to say
who's going to be on the Republicans the
Republican stage to debate right and
we're at this dinner everyone's kind of
throwing their names well let me tell
you you know we know obviously Trump's
going to be there well what do you think
about the Santas well I think he has to
do it because he's got a perfect resume
right now why wouldn't you do it you
know he's going to do it and uh the
other person I think that's going to be
there is from Georgia it's uh uh what's
his last name um Brian camp not Camp
it's a ratzenberger oh man it's another
name anyways I'll think about I'll say
the name the governor of Georgia people
are talking about him running for
president what's Ryan Cameron Camp okay
yeah but then maybe I'm messing it up
with another name and then I said what
about zeldin so zeldon's not capable
he's very boring I said dude the guy
lost by only five percent in New York to
hokel what are you talking about yeah
but he's boring they're trying I said I
know I know they're trying to get him to
become the chairman of RNC but he's not
running to be there because he thinks
he's going to be president sometimes
people run to get a job like a lot of
people run to get a job on the
administration of who they think is
going to win okay hey hey you sit this
one out I'm going to give you this job
hey you sit this one out I'm going to
give you this job and it's a negotiation
right kind of like that day we all saw
Elizabeth Warren Amy Bernie everybody
just sits it on hey we're all getting
behind Biden and here's what you're
going to be doing fantastic we're all
happy this kind of worked out so
I I I'm convinced
um I'm convinced we were debating uh
James D Eugenio he wrote the book JFK
Revisited with Oliver Stone and he's
turned into a movie documentary all this
stuff and I said the swamp killed JFK no
well yeah of course the swamp killed JFK
the swamp killed Lincoln no no it wasn't
Lincoln I said well you know it wasn't
swamped now well you know all this other
stuff well he was kind of doing stuff
that his own party didn't like civil
rights all this what are you talking
about well yeah well the swamp kind of
went after Reagan but not not
necessarily well Reagan was kind of
trying well the swan went after swamp
one after Trump right yeah well well
then who is not part of the swamp in
politics today what are you talking
about who is not part of the swamp give
me names today that are not part of the
swamp that have roles inside they're
silent they can't say anything it's
McConnell swamp it's Biden swamp is
Obama swamp is you know Bush all these
names you're going through to be part of
the swamp
so for me
um
some people want a job for resume some
people want it for a nicer profile on
Wikipedia Some People Want it because
they want to brag about it some people
wanted to make money you don't know
everyone's positive and negative motives
all I'm saying is when when President
Bush is picking his team and you're
bringing them inside if CIA can't find
that four fact if wmd was right how does
President Bush or not just President
Bush any other president no four fact
people you're bringing and their motives
are positive or negative maybe some of
these other guys the dick cheneys of the
world and Donald's motives were negative
maybe his is pure but others are
negative do you think that
responsibility lies on the person that
picked those people or no all right let
me get down to the Brass tax on this do
you think that George Tenet gave Bush
the advice or gave him the information
that he gave him at wmd because George
Tenet wanted to make money no in that
sometime a Rumsfeld and Dick Cheney I'm
talking about okay the thing about tenet
is he should have fire tenant I don't
keep a tenant why do you keep a tenant
his loyalty is not for you you get rid
of a tenant I I don't your dad was
working with the CIA your father like if
there's anybody I'm trying to see who
gave the advice to keep tenet who was it
your dad's got a lifelong resume of all
this stuff so maybe a part of it for me
is not even on W because I'm convinced
George would have W would have called
his father to say hey what do we do with
tenant and his father probably gave him
some kind of fatherly advice and 10 of
the influence was probably from props it
says okay let's keep tenant why are you
keeping tenant I think George Bush would
just disagree with you on this one okay
for the exact reasons I said before you
know during the transition he interviews
tenet he likes tenant he thinks tenants
non-political and tenants knowledgeable
simple as that and it wasn't like he had
his guy no president wants to have his
guy at CIA what you want is an honest
broker at CIA who will tell you the
facts whether you like the facts or
don't like the fact slam dunk that's
it's a fact that's what he believed
because that's I mean this is what the
CIA concluded but to to say Ari you you
and I you're in odds guy if you like
sports it's all about odds we're in the
odds game
it's a slam dunk you know like when who
was the one guy that said Schiff Adam
Schiff is it Adam Shifty the interest no
Congressman yes yeah you listen it's
proven we have a Intel listen Russian
Russia oh okay what are you talking
about all right so with all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetamin it says future
looks right here future looks bright
here we got them in white we got them in
Black we got them in red are black on
black sold out these are about to sell
out if you haven't ordered one yet we
had a person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people were in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]